Miley Cyrus speaks out about being
groped and grabbed by a fan the 26 year
old singer took to social media on
Monday to share the footage from the
incident that went down over the weekend
adding her own commentary to slamming
online trolls saying she was asking for
it
because of what she was wearing quote
she can be wearing what she wants she
can be a virgin she can be sleeping with
five different people
she can't be grabbed without her consent
[Music]
the clap back comes after Miley was
forcibly grabbed and kissed by a crazy
fan while exiting her Barcelona hotel
with husband Liam Hemsworth a source
tells et that the former Disney star was
unsettled by the incident but is now
doing fine getting healthy is more
important than anything else
[Music]
the couple was in Barcelona when the
incident went down Miley was there to
perform at Primavera Sound 2019 on
Friday she's currently promoting her new
EP she is coming which dropped the same
day she is coming as the first of three
EPS Cyrus has planned to come out this
year with she is here expected to come
out in the summer she is everything will
drop toward the end of the year